vous écoutez europe 1 et les 22h16
l'invité de retenue avec emmanuel faux
ce soir emmanuel vous recevez le
scientifique jean marc jancovici il a
participé au pacte écologique de la
fondation nicolas hulot
il a créé la société carbone 4 et
l'animent le projet shift pour accélérer
la transition énergétique
et puis jean marc jancovici publie
dormez tranquilles jusqu'en 2100 et
autre malentendu sur le climat chez
odile jacob
notre invité est bardé de titres et
diplômes puisque vous êtes aussi
ingénieur x de l'école polytechnique
bonsoir jean marc jancovici
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous à quatre
semaines je le disais de l'ouverture de
la com 21 à paris à la fin du mois et
alors que nous en parlions tout à lire
dans le journal le président de la
république est en voyage en chine chez
le premier pollueur de la planète et
qu'il a obtenu cet après midi un accord
de principe un engagement de pékin pour
que justement à paris soit signer un
accord juridiquement contraignant vous
propose tout de suite d'entendre ce que
disait tout à l'heure le chef de l'état
s'était dit bien quelques heures à pékin
il était tout à fait décisif que je
puisse venir ici à pékin pour affirmer
avec le président chinois
notre volonté qu'il y ait un accord à
paris mais pas n'importe quel accord un
accord ambitieux un accord contraignant
un accord qui puisse être vérifié et
c'est tout l'enjeu de cette conférence
l'échec est toujours possible d'ailleurs
il a eu lieu l'échec à copenhague en
mais le succès est aussi possible et il
dépend de nous aujourd'hui avec la
déclaration que nous venons de publier
nous avons posé des conditions qui nous
permettent d'entrevoir un succès voilà
françois hollande devant l'envoyé
spécial d'europe 1 david do quand jean
marc jancovici quelques raidillons peut
accorder à cet engagement des chinois
allait vers un accord ambitieux lors de
la cop 21 est ce que vous y croyez
vraiment je vais rebondir sur deux des
choses qui sont contenus dans la
déclaration du président la première est
dit copenhague a été un échec s'il
souffre et c'est à copenhague que
l'objectif politique des deux degrés a
été mis sur la table pour la première
fois il se trouve que c'était par
l'adversaire politique du président du
bo bo enfin copenhague a pas du tout été
un échec
quand répète de degré d'émission de gaz
et 2 degrés d'augmentation des
températures c'est un objectif qui est
qu'il n'y ait pas plus de deux degrés
d'écart donc la température moyenne en
2100 et la température moyenne il y a en
gros un siècle
c'est ça l'idée et c'est directement
proportionnel aux émissions de gaz à
effet de serre qui auront lieu entre
1850 et 2100 en gros vous prenez les
émissions x bon coefficient et vous
obtenez l'augmentation de température en
2100 et alors quand on dit déclarations
ont juridiquement contraignante en
décembre ça veut dire quoi alors c'est
la deuxième chose qu'il faut relever
dans la déclaration du président c'est
que en matière de traités parce que la
convention climat est un traité régie
par les nations-unies le juridiquement
contraignant n'existe pas c'est à dire
que si vous ne respectez pas vos
engagements des missions vous ne voyez
pas débouler chez vous les chars les
avions et les gens qui vous envahissent
et qui ferment autoritairement les
usines ça n'existe pas il n'ya pas non
plus de sanctions commerciales n'y a
rien donc en gros ce qu'on appelle
juridiquement contraignant ça n'est pas
du tout comme les français qui nous
écoutent l'entendent s'ils payent pas
leurs bêtes l'huissier des boulangères
laurent fabius à dire en aparté
aujourd'hui à pékin que on va pas mettre
les gens en prison
non s'ils ne respectent pas leur temps
dans le livre que vous avez cités tout à
l'heure j'ai fait une analyse de ce qui
s'était passé dans les pays qui avaient
ratifié kyoto après la signature du
protocole de kyoto en 1997 et ceux qui
ne l'avaient pas fait et l'enseignement
quand on regarde les chiffres on se rend
compte qu'il ya pas de différence entre
les deux donc en gros le vrai
déterminant de l'action n'est pas dans
le fait qu'on ait ou pas signer un
traité international
r c'est très important ce que vous êtes
en train de nous dire ce que ça veut
dire à l'issue du sommet de décembre à
paris on ne pourra pas vraiment dire il
ya un engagement formel dont les états
ne ne pourront pas auquel des états ne
pourront pas se soustraire avec le texte
il vient d'être cynique elle je suis
soit parce que je suis en train de vous
dire c'est que il ya une blague d'un une
des amies qui s'appelle brice lalonde
qui dit si on en est à la coop 21 ans
ex-ministre des hommes c'est que ça fait
20 ans qu'on n'a pas trouvé la solution
et ce n'est pas complètement faux
c'est à dire qu'on est face à un
problème complexe qui fait appel à
l'énergie c'est à dire ce qui est à la
racine du monde moderne et il n'y a
strictement aucune manière de régler le
problème à claques monde
ouah où que ce soit donc le fait qu'on
se réunissent pour discuter c'est une
excellente chose
par contre il n'ya pas une vie suspendue
avant paris est un problème résolu après
paris c'est pas comme ça du tout qu'il
faut voir le problème mais en plus jean
marc jancovici quand je vous disais tout
à l'heure peut-on croire
l'engagement de principe des chinois se
seraient valables pour les indiens pour
les américains parce qu'on sait bien
pour ses grandes puissances très
polluante et qui sont parmi les plus
gros pollueurs de la planète
il ya des enjeux économiques derrière
tout ça il ya des industries et c'est
pas du jour au lendemain on va mettre en
berne telle ou telle industrie pour le
plaisir de satisfaire un chiffre mis
dans un accord on est bien d'accord
alors le je vais donner un chiffre que
je trouve toujours éclairant comme vous
le savez le parc nucléaire français dont
on a beaucoup discuté dans ce pays
représente un peu plus de 60 giga watts
et des milliards de watts
le parc chinois au centre de centrales à
charbon donc 60 pour le nucléaire en
france le parc chinois de centrales à
charbon ses 820 gigawatts et il faudrait
que ces centrales à charbon
disparaissent tout je dis bien tout dans
les 30 ans qui viennent
si on veut avoir une chance de tenir
l'objectif des deux degrés ça c'est de
la physique de base qui nous permet de
le dire
pas une seconde les chinois ne vont le
faire juste pour les beaux yeux du reste
de la planète
d'ailleurs dans ce livre dans votre
livre jean marc jancovici vous vous avez
un plaidoyer un peu étonnant pour le
nucléaire où vous dit qu'il serait bon
qu au pays des cartes on fasse un peu
confiance aux scientifiques aux hommes
de science et qu'on cesse d'avoir le
nucléaire honteux oui quand vous lisez
je vais vous apprendre quelque chose en
ce moment là on est en train de parler
de climat le climat a notamment un
constat scientifique qui est produit par
une instance onusienne s'appelle le giec
entendu parler du giec les experts
voilà qui a été créée en 1988 il se
trouve que le nucléaire comporte
également son groupe d'experts également
sous l'égide des nations unies créée en
j'avais en entend parler dans les médias
sûrement jamais et c'est pas le fait des
gens qui s'occupent du sujet c'est fait
des médias décident de ne pas les
inviter
et la deuxième chose c'est que quand
vous lisez les rapports produits par ces
gens là vous obtenez des conséquences
qui sont mille fois moins dramatiques
que ce que les antinucléaires veulent
bien propagé sur les ondes ou dans les
journaux donc le
constat quand vous regardez d'à peu près
les faits c'est que ne pas faire de
nucléaire fait courir beaucoup plus de
risques que d'en faire sa vie dans la
vie on fait des choix
vous n'avez jamais le monde merveilleux
d'un côté et puis le monde abominable de
l'autre à un moment vous avez le choix
entre faire ou ne pas faire quelque
chose est bien le grand paradoxe pour un
certain nombre de gens qui nous écoutent
c'est que ne pas faire de nucléaire face
aux enjeux qui sont posés par le
changement climatique et le défaut
d'approvisionnement dont l'europe
souffre déjà en combustibles fossiles le
danger de ne pas faire de nucléaire est
considérablement supérieur au danger
d'en faire pour revenir à votre kit
dormez tranquille jusqu'aux 2100
jusqu'en 2100 est ce qu'il faut
comprendre que selon vous l'objectif de
ces fameux 2 degrés de réchauffement
climatique moyen ne pas dépasser d'ici
2100 c'est un objectif beaucoup trop
lointain beaucoup trop peu abstrait pour
que les opinions se mobiliser pour que
les états soient vraiment vertueux alors
il ya un chapitre qui parle de ça aussi
qu'il y d'abord le fait d'avoir mis de
1100 en avant des incarne le problème en
2100 vous serez mort vous enfants sont
morts enfin moi en tout cas je serais
mort je l'espère et mes enfants et mes
enfants très probablement donc ça
désincarné l'objectif de 800 vous en
foutez enfin je veux dire ce qui compte
c'est votre fin de mois le mois prochain
savoir si vous allez garder votre djabou
passe à écrire 2005 en 2040 ce qui est
ce qui est très difficile avec le
changement climatique c'est comme on est
en train de vivre une expérience
grandeur nature pour la première fois
faire des prédictions quantifier daté
précise relève quasiment de la mission
impossible
donc on peu après coup et il ya un
certain nombre d'exemples dans ce livre
dire ça c'est déjà une conséquence du
changement climatique mais dire à
l'avance je vous préviens que le 3
septembre 2022 a très exactement 7h48 il
va se passer tel truc ça n'a aucun sens
tout à fait impossible
et comme on n'est pas capable comme ça
d'illustrer des objectifs des dangers
possibles court terme
du coup c'est très dit ça rend très
difficile d'incarner le besoin de lutter
contre ça et le deuxième c'est la
deuxième chose c'est que quand on parle
de 2 degrés ça fait peur à personne
oui mais vous avez peur de 2 degrés vous
sur un siècle en plus est sur un siècle
donc ça veut dire ça lointain et pas
vraiment chiffrables nous dit où dort en
chantier or ce qu'il faut rappeler
encore et encore sur les ondes c'est que
la différence de température moyenne qui
nous sépare d'un d'une ère glaciaire
s'est simplement 5 degrés donc 2 degrés
c'est absolument massif à l'échelle de
la planète mais on se rend pas compte
parce qu'avec nos sens c'est juste la
température à paris aujourd'hui qu'on
voit et celle là elle bouche de beaucoup
plus de 2 degrés sans qu'il nous arrive
quoi que ce soit merci beaucoup jean
marc jancovici dormez tranquilles
jusqu'en 2100 et autre malentendu sur le
climat et l'énergie c'est publié chez
odile jacob et on fera comme ça tout au
long du mois de novembre des éclairages
et pour comprendre un petit peu les
enjeux de cette coque 21 et pour éviter
justement aussi tous ces malentendus
dont vous ne parlez merci d'être venus
ainsi